AND SAVE THEIR OWN CHILDREN.
>> Sean: STAY THERE, DAN,
WE’RE GOING TO GET TO YOU.
KEVIN CORKE IS STANDING BY WITH
THE LATEST.
WE’VE BEEN WATCHING THIS NEWS
UNFOLD ALL NIGHT IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., WE HAVE NOW
CONFIRMED TO HIM PRESS WAS TOLD
TO LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE AT
8:45:00 P.M. BY THE
SECRET SERVICE.
HERE WAS THE FULL REPORT AND YOU
COULD SEE THE PROTEST ON GOING.
OBVIOUSLY ATTEMPT NOW IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., -- A LOT OF
THINGS GOING ON THERE, KEVIN,
WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> LET ME TELL YOU TWO THINGS,
YOU’RE RIGHT ABOUT 8:45 OR SO,
THE SECRET SERVICE TO THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS TO
EVACUATE.
USUALLY WHAT THAT MEANS, SEAN,
AS IF YOUR OTHER ON THE NORTH
ONE, YOU DON’T WANT TO BE
DOWNWIND OF ANY DISPERSAL
TECHNIQUES.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF THEY’RE GOING
TO USE PEPPER OR SOME SORT OF
OTHER AGENTS, THEY WANT TO CLEAR
AN AREA, ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE
ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE, THEY DON’T
WANT YOU ON THE NORTH LAWN.
IT COULD ALSO MEAN, SOMETIMES IT
DOES, THE PROTESTERS HAVE GOTTEN
TOO CLOSE TO THE FENCE LINE.
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT WAS THE
CASE, BUT AS YOU’VE KNOWN, SEAN,
THE MOB IS IN FACT ON THE MOVE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IN D.C.
WHAT THEY’VE DONE IN SEATTLE,
AND THAT’S GREAT AND AUTONOMOUS
ZONE.
IF THEY’RE CALLING COME AWAY FOR
FOR, BLACK HOUSE AUTONOMOUS
ZONE.
THEY TRY TO ACTUALLY SET UP SHOP
ON NORTH OF THE WHITE HOUSE
ABOUT A BLOCK EAST OF NORTH
LAFAYETTE PARK.
THEY WERE ARTY THERE THINGS TO
MURIEL BOWSER, WHO CORDONED OFF
A PART OF 16TH STREET AND
RENAMED IT "BLACK LIVES MATTER
PLAZA."
SORT OF SCOOTED THOSE BARRICADES
OVER ALONG WITH SOME FENCING.
HOWEVER, THE SEPARATISTS HAVE
BEEN HIT BY A MASSIVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE, SO AT
THIS HOUR IT’S STILL UNCLEAR HOW
MUCH AUTONOMY THEY MAY BE ABLE
TO SECURE.
SOURCES ON THE GROUND IN FACT
ARE TELLING US THAT THERE ARE
DOZENS AND DOZENS AND AGAIN,
DOZENS, OF MEN AND UNIFORMED
WOMEN IN THE AREA.
AS WE GET PICTURES WE WILL PASS
THEM ALONG.
MEANWHILE THEY WANT TO TELL YOU
THIS, AUTHORITIES HAVE MOVED IT
TO SAY THE STATUE OF OLD
HICKORY, ANDREW JACKSON,
ANARCHIST SOME OF THE PROTESTERS
DEFACED THE STATUE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THEY TRIED TO PULL IT DOWN.
THAT TOO WAS RIGHT THERE IN
LAFAYETTE PARK DIRECTLY ACROSS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
THANKFULLY LAW ENFORCEMENT MOVED
IN TO PUSH BACK THE MOB AND TO
PROTECT THAT HISTORIC STATUE.
I’M GOING TO MAKE MY WAY OVER
THERE AND SEE WHAT ELSE I CAN
LEARN ON THE GROUND.
IF I GET MORE BEFORE YOUR HOUR
IS UP I PROMISE TO PASS IT